Salve youtubers Benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito
ve lo siete ricordati grazie mille
davvero
anche un regalo dai Non dovevate voglio
aprirlo subito che cos'è
Siete dei grandissimi pezzi di
come dicevo prima di iniziare la
recensione vorrei consigliare un paio di
canali Il primo è quello di H fisso
un ragazzo che fa musica rap veramente
molto molto buona e a caccafisso se vedi
se guardi il video Ti prego di mettere
una canzone come video di risposta a
questo in modo che la gente non deve
impazzire per guardarla Io ti
consiglierei quella del dittatore che
per preferisco Poi fai tu e soprattutto
lo ringrazio per avermi fatto la grafica
del canale ovviamente non mi sono
dimenticato di After Effect ita che è
quello che ha fatto la grafica prima
linko anche il suo Canale ovviamente
perché mi sembra giusto così il secondo
canale che anzi il terzo quindi sarebbe
il terzo canale che pubblicizzo è quello
di Vale Savi finalmente finalmente
riesco a pubblicizzarti perché ti giuro
è da tanto tempo che volevo farlo perché
meriti davvero e una una cantante
soprattutto coverista che fa le cover di
altre canzoni ma
che c'è nelle grotte due devono
sopravvivere al freddo e alla mancanza
di cibo eccetera tutte le cose della
sopravvivenza in mezzo al nulla
non vi ricordo un altro film
numero 5
A live i più Vecchiotti Vecchiotti
Intendo la mia età 22 23 25 anni anche
20 possono Ricordarsi che qualche anno
fa davano in TV Un film
chiamato a live lo davano spessissimo in
televisione spessissimo e di cosa
parlava questo film Live un gruppo di
ragazzi su un aereo si schiantano nelle
montagne innevate e devono sopravvivere
al freddo e alla mancanza di cibo
plagio perché la trama è uguale identica
Tralasciando la sottigliezza dello Yeti
ma proprio lasciandolo perdere Tra
l'altro succedono le stesse identiche
cose perché in live loro ad un certo
punto arrivano al punto tale da
mangiarsi pezzi di carne di cadaveri
perché non riescono più a trovare cibo
per non morire
di fame e senza forze mangiano pezzi di
cadavere e guarda caso succede questo
anche nel film di Yeti Yeti sono passati
un po' di anni perché mi sembra che il
primo film sia del 94 Alive Mentre
questo è del 2008 sono passati un po' di
anni ma la gente non dimentica ragazzi
non è che il film sono passati 20 anni
Allora il film scompare Puff scompare No
no rimane e qui non è che si sono
ispirati e uguali identiche la trama
ripeto tralasciando il coso peloso che
cammina e mangia tutti che per fortuna
in Alive non c'era anche perché era una
storia vera quella di Alive
numero 4
Cliché Io come sapete ho visto un sacco
di bimovies Z Movies e so che anche
buona parte di voi ha visti ne ho visti
tantissimi quindi sapete di cosa sto per
parlare ci sono dei cliché nei film ce
ne sono tanti però questa non è la sede
per parlarle ne vorrei citare uno che
c'è in questo film e che uno dei più
odiosi che io abbia mai visto in tutti i
film squallidi le parole migliori per
descrivere questo Cliché e farvele
vedere uno e commentarlo insieme si
vedono i due ragazzi e lo Yeti che li
sta per inseguire bello io ti ancora
lontano dai scappate
scappa
che problema c'è scappa e via 200 metri
corri
mbecille quale persona sarà di mente
rimarrebbe lì ma io capisco se l'hai
trovato a 20 cm dal tuo naso ma era
lontanissimo cosa stai fermi in due e
fermi Ah
beh dai datti una mossa stupido è
stupido fare così ma lo fanno sempre nei
film squali stanno fermi a urlare e
aspettare che il mostro di voi Oh dai
Perché fanno sempre così i registi
perché
numero 3 computer grafica perché
io non ho capito perché
ambienti tutto nelle grotte il lo Yeti
ha anche un costume fatto bene devo dire
la faccia è fatta bene Boh il corpo è
peloso Ma è uno Yeti non è che si può
fare di meglio Il fatto abbastanza bene
ci sono quelli che sono fatti con la
attori veri lo Yeti che fatto con un
attore vero e poi quando lui ti deve
correre nelle grotte lo fanno il
computer
sono cose che mi fanno spopolare il
cervello perché io non riesco a capire
il perché perché non c'è scritto da
nessuna parte il perché l'altro fatto di
uno squallore indescrivibile tutto
pupazzoso tutto così i robottoso di un
altro colore di un'altra illuminazione
numero due Yeti
Salve Benvenuti ad una nuova puntata di
Squallor Quark quest'oggi parleremo dei
comportamenti molto strani che lo Yeti
può avere durante il periodo invernale
può rubare cadaveri
dormire con le proprie prede
strappare cuori a mani nude
morsicare al collo
stritola la testa a mani nude
e tipo picchiare con la gamba che ti ha
appena strappato
Sì per davvero ti picchia con la gamba
che ti ha strappato
foto
numero 1 l'epopea di gambe spezzate
Lasciatemi raccontare una storia allora
C'era una volta un ragazzo che insieme
ad un amico vanno a cercare la coda
dell'aereo perché dentro c'è la radio di
sicurezza
riescono a trovarla vanno in una grotta
trovo in questa grotta trovano uno Yeti
Allora tentano di scappare lo Yeti
riesce a trascinare l'amico ma riesce a
trascinarlo tutto tranne un braccio che
rimane in mano al protagonista di questa
storia Allora il protagonista rimane
bloccato in una grotta vede una via
d'uscita in alto
solo che non riesce ad arrampicarsi con
la radio Allora si lega alla radio alla
gamba per poter salire
Ok si arrampica si arrampica si
arrampica ma ovviamente scivola cade e
si rompe la gamba allora usa il braccio
dell'amico per fasciarsi la gamba
un po' disturbante ma ok Poi finalmente
Lui riesce ad arrampicarsi con entrambe
le gambe rotte e fasciate una da una
radio e una da una gamba e si fa tre ore
di camminata sempre con le gambe rotte
fino ad arrivare dei suoi amici e allora
lui dopo queste Poppea dopo lo Yeti dopo
le gambe spezzate tutto il sangue
addosso
stanchissimo e affamatissimo dopo 3 ore
riesci ad arrivare dai suoi amici e i
suoi amici lo accolgono
ho preso quel figlio di [__]
sento il cielo Garcia
con una pistolettata in faccia per la
precisione non è una pistola normale ma
è una pistola lanciarazzi segnalatori e
lui muore così come una merda poverino
si era fatto
un'epopea allucinante per arrivare fino
a degli amici con il braccio del suo
amico legato alla gamba e la radio
dall'altra e cade in enorme così con le
gambe spezzate e un buco in testa ma non
è finita qui perché alla fine del film
ci deve essere sempre il twistending il
finale a sorpresa E ovviamente quando tu
pensavi che tutti gli Yeti Sì perché
c'erano più di uno tutti gli Yeti sono
morti invece no si vede il ragazzo con
un buco in testa che si alza e dice Sono
ancora vivo e allora tu dici se sei
contento perché lui ha le gambe spezzate
un buco in testa e dici se riesci a
sopravvivere a questo può sopravvivere
al freddo e al gelo e alla fame della
montagna ma purtroppo si scopre che uno
Yeti è ancora vivo e finisce così
provo una pena immonda per quell'uomo se
tu hai la testa e il coraggio di legarti
il braccio del tuo amico per steccarti
una gamba rotta
Sei un genio meriti di sopravvivere a
qualsiasi altra cosa 2012 meteoriti
catastrofi inondazioni Barbara D'Urso
che conduce Pomeriggio 5 meriti di
vivere in eterno con un buco in testa e
due gamberotti ma in eterno quindi
questa è la recensione di quello
schifezza ombrosa di Yeti e vi ricordo
che la prossima recensione sarà la
recensione con il vincitore del terzo
concorso acidi mix ma veramente ci sarei
prima io